the phillies will send zach wheeler to
the mount today in hopes of taking game
one of this series he has been nothing
short of outstanding for this for the
fills this season that'll bring up
fernando tatis jr
machado goes
and a call strike three right down the
middle 99 on that heater
131 strikeouts on the year for wheeler
now runs one hit and a man left over at
first we're going to the bottom of the
first it is the padres nothing in the
phillies coming up and for the padres it
will be chris paddock he is four and
five with a four point six four era and
66 innings pitch for the padres here's
jt romuto
jt 261 with runners in scoring position
he's got two ducks on the pond infield
his back
the bouncer right side that's going to
get a run home it's also going to get
segora over the third rbi for real mutu
and the phillies take a one nothing lead
abc baseball get him over get him in
well done
and so that brings up bryce harper
again we just mentioned it but bryce
harper 23 runs batted in on the season
o2 pitch
pulled right side
it'll get the run home
and the phillies lead at two nothing an
rbi for harper is 24th of the year
that'll bring up andrew mccutchen
good change it by chris
mccutchen swings over the top of it for
strike three so chris paddock does
finally put an end to the inning but not
before two runs cross on two hits
and a costly error at the end of an
inning of play philadelphia too
so one
away and that'll bring eric hosmer to
the plate
2-1
ground ball hit towards first hoskins
diving towards the line he's got it
flips underhand a wheeler who runs to it
at first base great lead there by
hoskins he just floated it out over the
bag and wheeler ran under it and there's
out number two nice play by reese and a
nice toss he just he let him perfectly
it was like a wide receiver
going down the sideline just let him
perfectly bring up the pitcher
paddock who's a 0 for 22
at the plate
and the 1-2 pitch coming from wheeler
and a strike three call on the outside
corner second strikeout for wheeler
pitcher zach wheeler will lead off for
the phillies who have a two-nothing lead
chris paddock gets back to work
career 154 average
that number will go down
as chris panick strikes out zach wheeler
second strikeout of the night for chris
two down here's genius zagura
o2 pitch curve ball
strike three call that actually buckled
segura he was trying to get out of the
way of a fastball inside good hard ball
by chris gets him third strike out of
the afternoon for chris panic in a one
two three inning to retire the phillies
here in the third two-nothing phillies
out of the university of michigan
what two pitch check this swing at foul
tip
hung onto by jt tried to check the swing
but it just nicked the bat
and there's a strikeout
third for wheeler
and that'll bring up trent grisham
three and two the count on grisham
here's the payoff pitch
it's a called third strike
got him with a slider there
on the inside corner and grisham caught
looking that's the final out no runs a
hit and one left
we're going to the bottom of the fourth
here at citizens bank park phillies two
of the padres nothing hosper
who's in his fourth year with the padres
11th year overall in the majors
here's the wind in the one-two offer
check swing nope couldn't hold up and
hosper
fooled on a curveball there becomes the
fifth strikeout victim tonight for zach
wheeler the double play is still in
order it's first and third with one out
and paddock coming up
paddock squares again the o2 pitch and
the bunt is down up the first base line
but it goes foul they had profar coming
home but they'll have to go back because
that's a strikeout
on the failed bunt attempt
number six for wheeler
two down now but the lead-off man tommy
pham one of the padres hottest hitters
coming to the plate with an opportunity
to try to get the padres on the board
and the pitch
swinging a weekly hit ground ball to
short dede's got it feed second that'll
force out
caratini and that'll do it for the
padres no runs two hits to left by san
diego and we'll go to the bottom of the
fifth with the phillies on top two
nothing
reece who grounded the second his first
time up three strikeouts for paddock one
two swung on a missed strike three good
change up on the outside corner fourth
strike out of the afternoon for chris
paddock one away here in the fifth
brings up d.d gregorius
dede who's been out of the lineup since
early may with the
elbow impingement
that one is drilled deep to right field
it is gone
a blistering home run for dede gregorios
it's his fifth of the year
and the phillies lead it three nothing
what'd you say sir you wanted a hooded
three-iron oh i got one of those
i got one of those in my bag
and now alec balm another o2 offering
swung on a miss strike three good curve
ball by chris
strikeout number five on the afternoon
now for that
will myers will hit for chris paddock
and a strike three called on the outside
corner beautiful pitch from wheeler it's
his ninth strikeout
two outs here in the eighth inning
well that is going to be it for weiner
that'll bring up fernando tatis jr he is
one for three today struck out looking
in the first
doubled in the fourth rounded out in the
six that was all against phil starter
zach wheeler here's the o2
and todd t sent it out into the left
center field gap that might be another
extra base hit groningen's on his way to
third he's going to be waived jake's on
his way home he will score without a
throw and rbi double for tatis and the
padres are on the board of the ninth
that'll bring up jerks and profile
pro 4 with a fair ball down the line
that should tie it dontese has scored
grisham on his way and the padres rally
in the ninth against the philadelphia
pad
the phillies now with eight blown saves
in the last nine games
i cannot believe this has continued to
happen
here's brad miller
three three game bottom of the 10th two
on one out
no balls two strikes
the pitch
swing and a high fly ball deep right
center field going back
and it is off the
fence and in play and it's won the game
as it'll be a double for brad miller and
in to score is mccutchen and the
phillies have won it miller circling the
bases
as he has walked him off here at
citizens bank park the phillies win it